you know what oh okay I wanted to go
before of course playing FM soft play
from 70 years ago chess player okay um
yeah okay my wasn't intended but again
it's still fairly it's a lean normal
position maybe I can get into some kind
of bin only here now that actually can
be an English opening by transposition
now not not a super great ruling but it
is I mean it's normal it's not what I
usually play so I'm getting at a five
you don't see all that often so very
ambitious way of doing it black hill
yeah get some space on the center quite
clearly but also beacons the center a
little bit if I've in particular so
we'll see how this works out film Knight
e4 to c5 I could do that probably not
get out of this first year out of the
sea farm is this a move it looks a
little bit looks wrong I do a bit
b5 1946 I mean he has to defend
Daphnia c7 b7 so 94 takes takes night a
4x got 95 just go down well if you can
go to default on any given chess
position and you can go to a 5 you need
a really good reason to go to a 5
instead of D form we'll see um I have a
very simple idea
a4 okay one Bishop e3 bishop before and
then winning the night with my typical
non subtle play by the side work I'd be
sure that it's good strange move let's
think about it for a moment okay let's
not think about it
okay I can click on a3 no cannot do it
and then Bishop a three years just just
good huh I mean if he has to play the
six this this has gone wrong so now I
can take this but I can also play this
that wins an exchange that's win the
exchange
okay so I mean what is the best let's
take first and then think about it
he might have before at some point but
then actually just opens up everything
for me em yeah yeah it's not something
to worry about after if why I cannot
take SD towards hanging but I'm
generally happy with the position
opening up that opens up like for my
looks and his king is of course not very
safe so what to do
91 I have 93 here also yeah that looks
good
rook takes rook the one that that wins
easily if he actually takes with the
rook taking f5 I don't want to take
right f5 is rook g5 it's not so nice
okay come on it's a quick let's be quick
am main danger is that I'm kind of
falling asleep looking at that position
here and then I'm losing the sometime
[Music]
in the group default for us anyway I
understand he does not want to have his
rope traded but still take it clean a
tree at 93 so it was not a huge problem
and yeah how do I get edges King what do
I just play the ending em I mean it's
just look quite good
take the night and maybe I can get to f3
would be helpful
ninety-eight probably then 95 is good
taking everything take a 3d seven and if
you take C 5 d 8 Hank so there's some
coordination problems
check now I shouldn't be back when I'm
eight it it would be higher learning so
just back what is the best way to do it
and I can't so take this
maybe let's just get rid of the back
ranked meat check I'd still store so
able to screw this up if I do something
completely terrible
check check check check
that's not really quick yeah and the
flat for faithful inhale extend ye
continues okay so yeah that was a really
good position all of a sudden I think 95
was really a bad decision I don't know
how bad but I I think it was quite
honest unnecessary also huh computer
wants to do this as well so it's not
really bad when I thought here here in
95 I 95 okay but Bishop keep in mind I
mean this is just more centralizing but
this seems to be not so bad why are here
c5 that's an interesting move that I did
not consider very interesting him yeah
I'm not I'm not a huge expert on this
particular set ups ever that's good
that's good it's really good
his ideas to play here
he's got controller with this of course
and the knight has one thing no no the
knight controls
and if I take everything's fine
but clearly very interesting yeah and if
I do something slow it's gone see this
is great yeah now everything works for
him
so night at 5:00 was okay if he does
that I did not see this at the arrow
also 95 wasn't an issue but this is an
issue it really is okay yeah after that
it's basically winning I mean I probably
didn't play in the most precise way with
the deserve it is very very favorable
and at one point and so forth I'm
winning also yeah interesting I've got
six five that's not a motif that I had
on the way that I do okay guys thanks
for watching